and if you were to start over today in
2013 would you release your films via
YouTube because some of the distribution
deals that you know I've read about that
you got for some of your films I mean it
was just amazing you could do them on
such a low budget and then tell us but
it really doesn't seem to exist anymore
there was the Wild West and we're hoping
for I mean for us the internet hasn't
moved fast enough to get you know to get
where it's going in terms of how can you
get revenue in order to get the
financing for the films that you want to
make would you consider you to battle
course what do you see in YouTube that's
so there's some people they'll say oh
it'll never it'll never stick around
there'll be so many copyright
infringement right well I think it's a I
think it's a beginning and I think then
they'll figure it out you know it's kind
of like how the studio's figured out
about eventually their contracts said
that that you know originally they would
say you know for thee for the US and
canada the rights for the US and canada
and then eventually it said for the
universe and tire in every medium now
known or able to be known by the mind of
man you know for eternity oh ok Thank
You Naruto Oh baby bug that doesn't
isn't really a planet anymore right but
i but i think that youtube and some of
these other you know online approaches
are they're gonna figure it out and
we'll be there ready to make films
you